hey guys now you know that i talk a lot
about working both hard and smart to
achieve your goals right to achieve
success in life
but did you know that if you overwork
yourself too much you can get burned out
and then it does the opposite this is
what happened to me recently the problem
with burnout is this you waste a lot
more time
because now you push yourself while
you're already tired burned out when
you're not you're 100 you don't think as
you usually do and you waste a lot more
time i heard this quote somewhere
burnout happens when you avoid being
human for too long
now you need to understand that there is
a big difference between just being lazy
and being burned out do you know the
difference do you know the signs of
being burned out
well if you don't let's take a look at
it
all right now the word burnout is not
old it was first used in 1974 by herbert
friedenberger and it is basically a
state of emotional mental and often
physical exhaustion brought on by
prolonged or repeated stress though is
most often caused by problems at work it
can also appear in other areas of life
such as parenting or caretaking or
romantic relationships according to
psychology today now a lot of guys don't
even realize that they are getting
burned out before it is too late so
let's take a look at the 10 signs of
burnout
unmotivated when you start to lose that
inner drive you know to achieve your
success to achieve your goals
feeling unmotivated a lack of motivation
for work or even
just for things that are home it can be
a clear sign that you're getting burned
out
it happened to me recently as well and i
i struggled just to get even out of bed
i just didn't feel like doing anything
and it wasn't lazy it was just i'm just
tired of everything
i had to drag myself through the day to
get everything done where normally i
would just go into it
full of power full of energy and just
get things done
but this
was the opposite
if this sounds like you then it might be
a clear sign that you are burned out
exhaustion feeling tired all the time
if you are exhausted
and unmotivated those two normally goes
hand in hand
and there's a difference between just
being lazy you know i'm just lazy i
don't want to do anything and really
feeling just tired you don't have the
energy to do things if you have burnout
exhaustion you're not just tired a
little bit here a little bit there every
now and then you're tired all the time
and this is not just a quick thing this
is not just for a few days few weeks
this might be something going on for
months even and it's not just physical
exhaustion is mental and emotional
exhaustion where you you've give given
everything and there's just nothing left
anymore
lack of focus
when you are yourself 100
when you are rested healthy and at your
100 you are alert focused and quick on
your feet but if you're burned out you
are not at your 100 anymore and it
affects your body your brain loses focus
concentration and you're more forgetful
as well and this started to happen to me
as well i started to forget even the
simplest of things and then it
influenced my productivity i got a lot
less things done
as i used to and then you know what
happens the work starts to just pile on
and for you is this just mountain is
just getting bigger and bigger it's just
like the snowball that just gets bigger
burnout
[Music]
increased illness
when you are burned out you just feel
depleted it influences your body and so
your immune system is not as strong as
it used to be anymore and so of course
it's easier for you to become ill this
is why hard-working people
those who work over hours push
themselves to the limit when they take a
quick break you know just for a few days
they get
ill immediately now most of you know
that i had covert right but what you
don't know is before covet i was getting
burned out and then i got a normal cold
out of nowhere
it took me two weeks to get better one
week just in bed my voice even
disappeared and then i knew
this is from burnout don't let this
happen to you
[Music]
physical symptoms now i've already told
you that burnout can have a big
influence on your body like on your
brain and also your immune system but
there are also other physical symptoms
like headaches shortness of breath
dizziness chest pain or heart
populations look burnout is not good for
you it's not healthy for your body and
you can develop serious problems like
digestive issues heart disease obesity
and even depression and this can happen
to you if you don't take care of
yourself in time
anger people who go to work while they
are burned out
they are easily a lot more easily
irritated by their colleagues by their
workload and just having to deal with
this rat race that we live in this may
let people burst out in anger and in
some extreme cases it can turn into
violence at work at home so you're
taking it out on people
who don't even deserve it just because
you are burned out
[Music]
anxiety you know when you slowly start
to get into burnout you can start to
feel more tension more anxiety with the
things that you have to do a lot of
people stress today stress is a big
problem in the world you know we design
new things
we are so smart with our technology and
everything that we invent everything is
supposed to go easier smarter right but
why do more people
get depression anxiety stress all of
these things and so with burnout it
starts to get worse and worse and worse
and worse
and
in such a degree that even your family
at home they don't even know you anymore
you just seem like not yourself even at
work people say the same things your
colleagues like hey man what happened to
you are you all right then you go home
you try to sleep but when you try to
sleep you keep thinking about everything
that you've got to do you lie there
awake and then you don't even get enough
sleep anymore and then you go to work
the next day you're more on edge
and that anxiety that stress it
interferes with your ability to be
productive and then it just feels like
everything is just too much for you to
handle the world is against you but
actually it's just you having burnout
not taking good care of yourself
when you experience burn up you are
already experiencing anxiety and stress
and so you sleep a lot less than you
used to and you're not you're 100
up here you focus a lot less you don't
concentrate as well as you used to and
you're just trying to hold on to
everything so in order to cope with all
of this some people start to rely on
coping mechanisms like drinking
smoking
unhealthy eating or even drugs this is
very dangerous especially if you start
to self-medicate
some people start to rely or get
addicted
to pills you can't function normally if
you don't get your sleeping pills if you
don't get your antidepressants or if you
don't get your drugs that is not a life
it's not a life where you need to start
to rely on pills just to function
normally
[Music]
you're not happy
you know you start to be that guy that
guy
who sees the world as the
glass half empty kind of guy you see
things
more negatively you experience
a lot more unsatisfaction from life in
general and that doesn't just happen at
work but everywhere you go because the
problem is within you a man sees
as he is if you are burned out you will
look at the world around you differently
and it won't be pleasant that is also
why a lot of people who experience
burnout they get depressed if you are
burned out you might start to experience
signs of cynicism detachment and with
this also comes a lack of accomplishment
other people will start to irritate you
more and it will feel like you just want
to be left alone all the time being
burned out is a serious condition that
you can't take lightly
loss of appetite you know some people
might start to eat more as a coping
strategy but some people might start to
eat a lot less
because you might think man i can get a
lot more work done if i just keep this
meal and then this one as well and and
this one before you know it it becomes a
habit you start to eat less you start to
lose your appetite and you lose a lot of
weight you become skinny
you know as a man you might feel that
responsibility to be a good man be a
good husband to be a good father to take
care of your family but if you overwork
yourself to such an extreme where you
start to get burned out you will do the
opposite if you're not yourself you
stress all the time you're a little bit
on edge here and there at home so your
children start to look at you a little
bit differently your wife looks at you
differently you sleep less you're
stressed all the time about work it's
just work work work work work what's
happening is you're pushing your family
away and then it influences your health
so you're not a strong pillar for your
family anymore if you are experiencing
any of these signs that i've mentioned
then this should be a big wake-up call
for you
take some time out
rest and become a human being again and
then
take a hard look at your life and then
make some changes number one make time
for yourself number two take more breaks
from work number three set limits to
your work routine four take good care of
yourself
that means nutrition and sleep five
develop a method or strategy where you
can better control your stress on a
daily basis
six prioritize better by scheduling your
priorities
seven plan for the future now remember
burnout is not just a quick thing that
you can try to fix you're not going to
get over it in a day you need
weeks to get over this so take some time
and start to take good care of yourself
be a human
and live
life
always remember this life is short so
don't waste yours
cheers guys